hello martin hey how you doing steve
good
very good so this is on my youtube
channel therefore people know who i am
who are you maybe you could make a brief
personal sort of introduction well as
you introduced said on google plus let's
start from the end and move backwards
okay uh i'm just approximately the same
age as you are right and uh i share the
same passion for languages that you do
right
especially when it comes to learning
them orally learning to actually speak
them right what i think what
differentiates us from what we said last
time is that you focus on vocabulary and
i just focus on jumping and learning
to use that right a very limited
pool of words um but i started doing
this when i was a kid and brought up in
brazil and i was kind of thrust into
portuguese at the age of six
in first grade but your your family was
not portuguese speaking
no uh my parents are american born in
new york in new york area and then i
they moved we moved to
uh this interior the center center of
brazil the state of goyas
when i was six years old at that time
brasilia wasn't built yet
but we lived actually very near what
would then become the the new capital
brazilian
so i was thrust into first grade didn't
know a word of portuguese and i had to
kind of learn
as a child would learn a new language
how long did it take you before you were
conversing in portuguese with your
buddies i don't know exactly you know i
i can't
measure my confidence
at that time it felt like i was
speaking within about three to six
months
and that's average i think for a
six-year-old right
and what does a six-year-old do
uh
he or she is going to learn a very
limited vocabulary
but
learn how to use that vocabulary to get
what she or he what they want and and to
do what they want
and that's what i've been doing ever
since
from there i
had to learn spanish and french
and then when i was 19
i
suddenly landed a job at the berlin
school of languages in rockefeller
center new york
because they had just lost their
portuguese teacher and they had several
executives signed up from general motors
for their total immersion course
so they were desperate and they just
grabbed me practically off the street
with just 19 years of age and i loved it
we i helped develop their total
immersion program
they
launched a
school that was specialized exclusively
in total immersion
on times square
and it was it was great and
the the next thing that happened was
that i
since i was out of
college teaching at berlitz i was going
to lose my student draft deferment
which means i would have probably been
shipped straight into the dmz in vietnam
if i didn't do something about it
so i went to my draft board
and
they said well if you
enroll in the bullet stool as a student
we can give you a student deferment
based on that
but you're going to have to study
languages full time
i say well wait a minute these are
intensive private lessons you don't do
these things full time so no no you have
to study full time
so i was effectively a prisoner in a
language school and i enjoyed every
moment of it and
that's where i come to great now a
question
a lot of people say
that you mentioned that you were six you
learned to speak portuguese within three
to six months
right i had the same experience uh we
emigrated from sweden i have no
recollection of having any trouble
communicating with
my classmates in montreal in english
like
seamless conversion from
uh english
so obviously young kids learn very very
quickly
um they're not inhibited there's a whole
bunch of reasons
the question always comes up you know do
we become less and less capable of
learning languages as we get older
and
and some people you think that once you
pass the age of 20 you can't learn a
language
or and for some people 40 is old for
some people
60 years old for us who are in our late
60s that's not very old at all so
question to what extent does age affect
our ability to learn languages
it does have an impact
of course
but the primary factor is not age
the primary factor is the attitude of
the student or the psychological
hang-ups that the student develops
and the primary reason
the student develops these hang-ups is
not his fault or her fault
it's the method by which he
is learning foreign languages
i taught at berlitz for several years
and every single student
began
his introduction
his story his life story about languages
by saying what guess what every student
said the first moment they walked into
my class it's difficult
i don't do i can't learn language i
can't learn marriages yeah i've tried i
i had this terrible experience that
terrible experience and my response is
no you are a natural learner of
languages
the problem is that you've been taught
with a classic traditional method which
focuses on
talking about the language not in the
language
which focuses on grammar and rules not
actually using those rules in practice
and which focuses on translation which
is
a total distraction in my opinion
during the
primary learning process
and so
i convinced them by in practice that
it's easy to learn a language and guess
what
those executives from general motors who
were signing up for those total
immersion courses
50s 60s some one in his late 70s
if they learned to speak portuguese in
two weeks
now
not enough to to uh you know
to have a high level conversation about
a technical field but enough to get
around and enough to do the same things
that you probably did
when you were six years old in a
classroom in montreal
just to
get what you needed and and communicate
what you needed right now
i'm prepared to believe that uh
a six-year-old
learns faster than a 16 year
old uh maybe not i
no let me just necessarily and the
reason i say that is they learn
differently but not necessarily faster
no no and and the 16 year old has
different needs and needs a much larger
vocabulary and so forth however
if kids come to canada or the us as
immigrants children right yes they're
younger than say 10 they will probably
end up speaking without an accent
if they arrive as teenagers
or even people who arrive as adults it's
far
less likely that they will end up
speaking without an accent
the younger people are more flexible
when it comes to the the phonology and
the phonetic mechanisms and and yes yes
in that sense but in an intellectual
sense a 16 year old is more prepared
and more disciplined and more able to
learn language more quickly so right
there are offsetting factors exactly
let's talk about us yeah
okay
and and you know let's face it our
memory isn't
uh and our memory a long-term memory
the the recording
of the facts to our memory banks and
then the act of retrieving those files
quickly when we need them is not as
strong as it was when we were 20.
but we can offset that
by learning smart and with technology
let me explain
okay and before we're done here i want
to give you the specific
uh technological tools
that i'm talking about right now
first of all
now here that you and i are talking
let's say we're talking in a foreign
language that
you're teaching me
um
i need to focus on understanding
i need to focus on on communicating
i don't have time
to
work on remembering or depositing that
information to my long-term memory banks
to my hard drive
i need to keep it in active memory
short term immediate memory so i can use
it now
all right
if i have to interrupt say well okay let
me try and write this down or let me try
and remember this word it's going to
break up the flow
so
the critical thing we i need
for that function
is a recorder
the same kind of recorder you're using
to record this video
or strictly an audio recorder there's
one available for the pc for the pcs and
there's one available for the max and
they're both free
okay
step number two after we have the lesson
i need to be able to
focus zero in on
those sentences or those words that i
want to record or remember
and so for that i should use a auto
audio editing
program
also available for the mac also
available for the pc for free
where i can see the
the
the pattern of the sounds on my screen i
can just highlight those and press the
play button as many times as i want to
hear those
back played back to me
that
is not only good for
you and me because our memory storage
and memory retrieval is not as efficient
as it used to be but it's also extremely
valuable for learners of any age
i'm teaching a young girl in russia
japanese
she's great
very fast
and she can use the material what i
teach her almost immediately
but two days later she says she was
focused so much on on communicating that
she forgot what she learned
you know in our lesson
and so she uses the recording
uh and the recording is a godsend i copy
it over to dropbox or any file sharing
software uh on the on the cloud
and then she just streams it directly to
her iphone or ipad and she can listen to
it anywhere in the world
and
uh okay so we're moving away from the
subject of age so
we're saying
this is critical because if you're older
this is critical for you
and the other side of it yeah the other
side of it is not just the technology
but the mnemonic devices
you can use while you're listening to
new words to make associations and that
also is a great aid for older folks like
us but it's also important for younger
folks yeah
you know i have to say that i share your
passion for languages but i don't agree
with what you're saying
okay let's that's that's debate no i
shouldn't say i don't agree i i agree
with some things i don't agree with
other things okay yes let's focus on
what you don't agree with uh no i think
the idea
uh the idea of recording a conversation
is a good thing
yeah uh i i'm not so convinced that we
go through this deliberate remembering
process i think that we
absorb a lot of information yeah forget
it relearn it forget it relearn it
and that process of forgetting and
relearning
and forgetting and relearning
how we learn
it's not bad it's like it's like uh
you know muscle exercise and you tear
muscle and then you rebuild you tear and
you're built right so therefore i never
for example have i had one conversation
i have recorded my conversations
with my tutors but i'm never that
motivated to listen to it again and
again and again
i would rather spend because i have a
limited amount of time to spend on
language right
i would rather expose myself to either a
new conversation
or
i happen to do a lot of listening and
reading
uh right now i'm following the events in
ukraine so i'm learning ukrainian
i want to understand what those
politicians are saying
uh
i don't spend a lot of time deliberately
trying to learn
but if you're paying for a big box for a
lesson with a tutor right right and you
don't have access to all these
conversations for free that you're
talking about right and the money is
important to you right
and then in order to
get the best
uh value for your money right uh
listening to the twitter at least one
more time
you
double and triple what you absorb from
that conversation
perhaps uh again i just think that that
it certainly has an effect
and i tell you what we do at link for
example we get a written report of all
of our mistakes
sometimes the tutor will actually record
it for us
i must admit i don't necessarily always
listen to the recording of the mistakes
uh
everyone's different
uh but i do review the mistakes and i
review the words oh i i totally don't
know i agree with you there
yeah i don't like re-listening to
mistakes
that is very demotivating
and it's not what you want to listen to
you want to listen to the proper
i don't listen to mistakes the the tutor
writes 10 or 15 or 20 correct phrases
and then records them so he's not
recording mistakes he's recording
in ukrainian or russian or whatever yeah
but that's can't
pardon that's that's canned
when a tutor sits there recording
sentences that's canned that's that's
that sound that begins to sound like
language tapes that you buy in the
internet or for from berlitz or somebody
like that except that they're relevant
to me because i remember having made
those mistakes oh okay good
so it's a question of where you want to
spend your time so i guess my
motivation is always to get more and
more of the language more and more
experience i am not so convinced that
the deliberate
focusing on learning this
on acing this whether it be the specific
thing see i think
that there are so many but we're going
to make so many mistakes there are so
many patterns in the language that we
have to master yeah that the
opportunity for the teacher to correct
my way to fluency is limited
massive exposure
is going to expose me to so many more of
these examples of the language here's
what's missing from this conversation
okay
it's called
the core
introduction to the language right the
oral introduction to the language in my
book it's a set of maybe 10 to 20.
what's the name of your book and where
do we find it
when you say in my book
the book that i'm in my mind
figuratively all right and my book
concretely as soon as i write it okay
but um in my approach
there are 10 or 20
core things
to build that basic foundation from
which you can take off
and when you're focusing on that it's
it's
you do need to
master that as opposed to going off in
10 different directions and so recording
it is very valuable
and we'd have to do a i'd have to
do a sample
a lesson with you in a language that you
don't know if i can find one
to to
demonstrate for you
and for your uh subscribers
exactly how that works
you know i agree with you that in every
language there are these basic patterns
how people ask questions how they say
things how they express cause and effect
how they you know why where when
tenses whatever there's certain basic
things
right and when i was learning romanian i
wrote out about
i don't know 300 sentences in maybe 15
or 20 different patterns
and i had a romanian person translate
them and record them for me
and that's how they say things in
romanian that's how they say this in
romania and i listen to it
and it's useful and it's something that
i review from time to time
but i personally have never found that
i'm able to sort of nail down this
foundation and then build on it
instead i find that my ability to
understand remember use these basic
phrases the foundation gradually
improves over time
and the more exposure i have
to the language
the more when i go back to review these
the more sense they make
i agree with you in one point yeah
when you're starting to learn a language
aiming for perfection
in the early stages is very inhibiting
and that's true with any learning with
any subject
it's more of a molding sculpting process
where you start with a
blur right
and then gradually begin to shape that
into something that becomes more
understandable and clearer i agree with
that i agree i i liken it to wandering
in a fog
and the fog
very slowly dissipates
but it's a very gradual process
so there's no one single way or the
right way of learning languages each
person is different
you for example focus on vocabulary and
vocabulary building as a tool right as a
as kind of a central axis around which
everything else kind of revolves
right
i focus on those
original building blocks core
oral foundation it's 100 oral
very little if no perhaps no reading and
writing
it's all about one-on-one interaction
uh in real world kind of
natural
uh language exchange and i i it's so
it's so hard to talk about it right
a 15-minute sample when anyone else can
not only that's watching this can not
only
see what we're doing but also learn as
well okay but let me ask you a quick
question
getting back to the issue of age
uh
have you found when you were a teacher
at berlitz and you've had other
experience you're helping this russian
girl learn
japanese
is there a difference in the ability to
learn of a 30 year old
between a 30 year old 40 year old 50
year old 60 year old
they're on average
yes we're averaging out the experience
of many different individuals all right
yes um
a uh
generally an older person is slower to
record
the material but once they do they're
slower to forget
okay
i remember going back to when i was a
six-year-old
come i returned to the united states for
a while when i was nine
after less than three months maybe six
months
i couldn't speak the language anymore
right because i was totally disconnected
from portuguese it was still in my brain
you were nine years old
i was i came back when i was nine so i
had been there for three years right and
i don't know how long it took probably
six months to a year or three i can't
remember exactly but at some point
after i returned to new york and i was
totally disconnected for the language
from the language
i could not speak it
it was gone right from my active right
side of my brain it was still there
so when i returned again at the age of
13
now another four years had gone by
it was like walking and i started
hearing the language
it was like walking into a dark room
and someone is turning switching the
light on and suddenly
it was all back
so um
compared to what had compare that now to
what happens to us
we may be
on average if we're older slower to
record and remember and really get it
but we're also going to be a lot slower
to forget
it has something to do i guess with the
ratio of the passage of time to our
to the amount of time we've already been
on the earth
maybe i again i'm not convinced i think
uh i think our neurons stay pretty uh
plastic
and uh
again i believe yours might because
you're in good physical shape you have
good cardiovascular you know
articulation all these things are a
factor but it on the average when at
berlins
the older uh students
um
it took longer to
i would imagine that that's the case but
i think it also has to do with
flexibility
confidence
oh yeah uh lack of inhibitions so if you
have an older person who is confident
and not not inhibited i also believe
that that the the um
anyway we're gonna we're gonna have
another opportunity to talk about this i
agree with this it's only one of many
factors exactly and the other factors
should be can be a lot more important
there you go on that point
we will leave uh agreeing about the
importance of passion
in learning languages
and that there's more than one way to
skin a cat and uh it's been a great
conversation so uh we'll end it here
otherwise i suspect we can go on for a
couple of hours
especially if we go into all the other
topics exactly so which we can do some
other time
great so thank you very much martin i
really enjoyed it thank you bye for now
bye